[Music]
the full Dancing with the Stars at
season 23 cast finally reveals the
family gets bigger every season the
names were announced on Good Morning
America
Tuesday et had already told you a lot of
the competitors names
we've got Marcia Brady marine McCormick
paired with Artem it's really exciting
Olympic gold medalist Lorri Hernandez
will dance with the Val Chmerkovskiy
disney star jake teo stan is teamed with
a newbie at jimmie johnson and little
women LA's ter joel gets Sasha Farber
Amber Rose is with returning pro Maksim
Chmerkovskiy we're gonna be the the fun
couple in this competition for sure
Derek Hough is also back he's with
Marilu Henner while Whitney Carson and
gets Ice Ice Baby himself Vanilla Ice
former NFL player Calvin Johnson is with
Lindsey Arnold babyface is paired with
Allison Holker and IndyCar driver James
Hinchcliffe is set to compete with
Sharna Burgess and thus later gets a
former presidential hopeful Rick Perry
this is a multiple win for me country
singer jana kramer is paired with Gleb
and Cheryl Burke is back competing with
Ryan Lochte as part of the DWTS
announcement ryan issued a public
apology on GMA for his scandal at the
olympics i take full responsibility I'm
human I made a mistake a very big
mistake I just want to move forward and
and put on your dancing shoes put on my
pins
[Music]
you
[Music]